so I would like to know how many of you
are running elasticsearch in your
company's how many applying to run
elastic search engine companies and how
many of you dealt with relational
databases oh no how it is okay perfect
so when I started working for for this
company for I'll which is currently
cotija called I hard media it used to be
called clear channel communications I
started working as DBA for relational
databases and at some point somebody
told me that I should take a look at
MongoDB that was my first honest no
skill database and I went through
literally cultural shock when I started
reading a book about MongoDB I was like
no transactions it can't be i did a
literally close the book and i just know
i'm not gonna this is BS it can't work
it can be used when can you use the
system without transactions tell me
where it's impossible so it was quite a
shock to me and I know I told it to two
guys but I thought maybe I should just
know this is this seems like total BS
maybe she just quit and go work on some
bank and be happy doing the square
databases but I stayed and it was quite
a ceiling right at some point the new
system that came under my management was
elasticsearch elasticsearch deals like
it it kind of known its tabled like
relational database have hash tables and
inelastic search and you can index the
table so you create you have table you
can index it in elastic search is kind
of opposite a less sexual search doesn't
think that original data is important
what is important is index data being
able to find the data so when you load
data into the elastic search it actually
create indexes and you also also can
save the original data if you want but
not always you can just tell
elasticsearch save a few fields so you
can find original date in some other
database you don't have to
essentially you have index instead of
table you have index and maybe some
original date if you want to
elasticsearch runs also the structure is
different I kind of got used to one
server that handles all the data in one
place here the data is a kind of
distributed between several processes
each process called is called a note and
usually trans on separate virtual server
or physical server but you know you can
run several nodes on one server and that
would be fine so the problem with in in
this situation you have to configure
every server or every node separately so
you have to create a configuration file
you have to install plugins you have to
do all this stuff but since it's not one
server you have to think about it ok now
when something happens when developer
come student says I need to add one more
configuration parameter to you to
elasticsearch configuration file you
actually have to go and if you have five
nodes you have to go SSH to every note
shin-bi you know whatever editor you're
using to change this parameter at this
parameter restart elasticsearch make
sure that it's restarted fine and then
you know go to another server do the
same thing and if you have more than one
cluster of elastic search which you
probably would have because you would at
least you will have staging you know and
production oq in production it becomes
quite and nightmare because it will
become your full-time job just going
into the service changing something
restarting and then you forget to do
something on the server and then you
know then it becomes a disaster so when
i started when i started doing
elasticsearch developers came to me an
amp is all made application that runs
behind the behind our application i
heart application so amp is called it's
kind of you know all main back end it
consists of several systems consist of
the code and they were they wanted to
use the elastic search so ok no problem
i created
clusters and production class that has
actually seven servers stage in class
that has three servers and development
cluster has three servers then second
kind of group of developers came to me
it's called radio aided I just shortened
it here re and they wanted their own
clusters they don't want it to be on the
same cluster with amp because they
didn't want to know screw up their data
and AB did not want them because they
were afraid that you know they are going
to screw up the data so okay fine I have
six clusters and each of them has no
several servers okay no problem then
Marvel came along and our EVP last he
really likes you know shiny
presentations shiny kind of you know
tools that they show you in the nice
graphs and nice you know tags how system
behaves so he liked it we installed
model unfortunately we have to install
separate model cluster for each of your
clusters so in a result and Marvel it's
kind of a tool that allows you to
monitor your elasticsearch cluster and
eat itself stores this monitoring
information in the elastic search so for
each marvel I have to create another
elastic search cluster of course it
wasn't that big so I can use just one
server because it's not that important
if it crashes I just know recreate no
problem okay no problem there elastics
then like this stack elasticsearch
logstash Cabana came along logstash
cable allows you to collect information
from your logs on all of your systems
and then save it to elasticsearch again
and then you can do a lot of nice things
to it but that resulted in more elastic
search clusters and then other
developers came to me and say oh you
know what I going to create a lasting
search cluster and even just kind of
experiment and I want to have elastic
search class that that the trans latest
version because we are not up to date
you're running the old version so we had
so many clusters currently we have more
than 20
in my room I don't even know exact now
but I wanted to calculate but I forgot
so because quite a nightmare so if you
guys decided to run elasticsearch if
your develops 14 that you should think
about its configuration software if
you're using puppet if using chef if
using salt fine if you're not using any
of the systems that just come up with
your own scripts you should not be going
into each server and making you know
changes manually just write some script
that would automatically ssh to all the
servers and do whatever you know
operations necessary for for elastic
search configuration file to be updated
and elastic search it started in in chef
we came up with this idea we have a row
we have like chef in general how many of
you know which chef is okay so chef is
configuration software that allows you
to define a node which usually separate
server and it allows you to specify what
scripts installation scripts run on this
node and you know what parameters they
use for that particular node so this is
an example of the node and if you know
that there is roll is clustered
production you know long name so this
note will be part of this elasticsearch
cluster this elasticsearch cluster is
defined as a role in chef you can define
the role and the main part of the role
is actually run list if you look down
there run list it runs elasticsearch
roll elasticsearch role would run
several scripts it would install
elasticsearch if it's not installed it
will create configuration file it will
install some plugins if they need to be
installed but all the parameters it will
take from this role so this role will be
assigned to all seven production notes
in this way you will have everything
exactly the same across all the nodes so
for example m cluster name should be the
same on all the notes elasticsearch
version should do the same on all the
notes you know install tab is actually
our software so we're running we're
doing a lot of interesting things we are
writing our own plugins and
elasticsearch installed up just lets the
installations clip no way to prove the
latest versions kind of version of the
plug-in you also can specify an above
masternodes and a number of replicas and
it's all will be the same across all the
nodes in the cluster also we have an i
just don't want to go into more details
but main idea is if you're envious you
know trying to round elastic social
setting up to an elastic search come up
with the idea how to specify parameters
in one place for all the nodes in the
same cluster otherwise you will be just
no swamped you'll be doing that all the
time 24 hours a day trying to configure
your elastic search clusters and instead
lastic search is the only system that
for some reason you know just exploded
in our company because we have manga we
have Cassandra but none of them I used
as wide as elastic search so now
currently when developers so and that
would allow you to kind of simplify
things so when the developer comes comes
to you and says okay I want
elasticsearch class that I want to try
something out you'd be able just to ask
six questions and pretty much set up
elasticsearch cluster according to the
answers so you'll have questions listed
here and that's pretty much it so this
is negative money showing it
automatically confusion configure it to
automatically send you notifications
when something bad happens to your
cluster you can monitor number of shirts
you can manage your number of number of
replicas you can mention number of
shirts per cluster because these systems
are kind of you know difficult to manage
in a sense that any developer can come
in and do something really bad you
know they change they for some reason
they decide to change number of no
replicas to zero which means your data
is not redundant anymore so which means
if one of the shares
becomes corrupt your you have to restore
from the backup so you have to kind of
be diligent about that in order to
assist them to be reliable of course us
you also need to monitor general
parameters for the server I have all the
laptop so it doesn't allow me just kill
very well so this will this is the
example column initially consistent
women ensure all the interface is the
manager you know that kind of general
linux stuff additionally I manager it's
kind of advanced it's called
elasticsearch advanced amateur that
number of replicas is the set to the
number that I know that I know about it
also checks the cluster if it's an alert
me if it becomes yellow or red because
elasticsearch allows you to kind of bid
one stay with one request to see how
zabil of your cluster so this is marvel
we highly recommend model very good and
it's kind of at a glance this is summary
and even at the glance you can see that
my my production cluster is not very
healthy because although it has seven
notes and but CPU is running around
twenty percent on many of them which is
very very high cpu usage although number
of requests is not that high if you see
a number of coil you could request is
around 500 per seconds which is not that
you know you can do much better than
that and I swear to God I didn't plan it
but right here we have a drop we just
had an outage about two hours ago yeah I
swear I didn't plan it I didn't do it
super presentation but literally be
hosted by station they had an outage so
it kind of shows the information it's
also very useful it kind of has
information about what happened to the
cluster like during the time period you
can see what happened to the cluster and
you can actually see
that cluster became red at some point
and you can click and see what was the
status of the cluster at that moment
what happened what shirts were not
available that it became bread this is
very good feature and you know this this
is very good system for my nature I
really like it you can use head plugins
we use it a lot to show information
about your shirts so here in the class
that i have three nodes on the left and
for each index it shows the information
about the shirts currently scheduled
this is simplified cluster we only have
one sharp / index bit so they don't
break our indexes into smaller pieces I
am NOT going to go into details why we
should be breaking them into smaller
pieces but we are not doing it right now
so it's shared number zero usually if
you have more shards it will show you
one two zero one two three something
like that it shows you primary shirts
the shares that are taking the the right
requests and this is kind of slave
shirts that are taking the read requests
it's not like manga it's not like we
have one server that takes all the
rights and all other servers of slaves
it's not like MySQL when you when you
have once order that is master that
takes rights and all the disorders are
slaves and you can read from them only
you cannot update them it's on shared
level once your this primary and takes
rights and the other shirts a secondary
they're like slave shots they only take
read requests you can see what server is
master so it's a great way to see you
information so questions
are you guys using virtual or physical
are we are using virtual and physical
we're using carnivia for production the
class that I showed you in Marvel it's
all physical servers but we are planning
on using we are using virtual in staging
and development and we are planning to
use hopefully virtual in new data center
but quite honestly we haven't run on a
virtual kind of we did not run
production cluster with the full board
we don't know how school what kind of
backup are you guys using like you do
snapshots to a different like NFS or we
are doing snapshots we are clapping our
snapshots to the Korean company that
copies them to some Phoenix location
something like that so in case something
happens to all data center we have
backups we also have like snapshots
we're currently testing because we know
it's it's it's quite embarrassing but
just recently upgraded to version 1.4
from 10.9 2.3 and 0.9 upon still did not
have snapshots so what we did we stop
the balancer and we just copied the data
files into separate location it wasn't
very good method currently we're
switching to snapshots thank you we also
have the multi multi data center or is
just a one send data center ah it's one
data center yeah we're being another one
but we don't have cross data central
replication yet is there a reason you
have a separate cluster for marble yes
we don't want to have situation when our
cluster goes down and we have zero
monitoring information about it so if
you store information like management
information that Marvel uses in the same
cluster when this cluster for something
happens to it it goes down we still want
to to have what happened to it what was
it overloaded with cpu time or something
like that and that separate
elasticsearch cluster will allow us to
see it unfortunately the thing that kind
of bucked me a lot you have to have one
elasticsearch marvellous elasticsearch
cluster per your
you know main cluster which kind of
annoying because you essentially quickly
double amount of clusters in the company
hopefully they will they promised me
that they're going to change that so we
may have then we'll make it have just
one single Marvel cluster fool all
clusters and how often do you guys plan
on taking snapshots when you do
implement it I currently my requirements
at the tape once a day not often and I
saw that you guys are using multi master
mode in the cluster right so are those
nodes are master unable or really master
master um so notes master master note
it's kind of it's it's kind of
misleading because master node is not
know that only takes rights master node
is a node that responsible for
maintaining information about the whole
cluster it maintains information about
where the sharp with the shirts
allocated which are the primary or
secondary but it's one master node that
maintains information about the cluster
test actually it's kind of know it has
to do with the data but it's not about
the data master and slaves all kind of
you know primary and secondary shards go
on a shark level yeah the reason why I'm
asking that question is because recently
we are also got the production sorry
papi lk and we got into the situation
because we are on AWS cloud subscale
auto scaling up down and we got into
situation where we had to master notes
and then are snapshots kind of not
correct yes so so what do you do about
to around that problem so you had two
masters you had split brain situation
right regarding to that situation and
then they recommended that you should
have one master and every other node as
a master and it would and you should
have a definition around that saying
that the next node can be master if the
master goes down only if the X number of
nodes are collecting that note right
another note to be mastered which is
monster neighbor so there is a parameter
in elasticsearch cluster its minimum
masternodes yes so that's what my
question like if you are minimum monster
norwich 5 that means finals are working
at a master no no no it means up five I
think it's kind of five only you need to
have five nodes in a cluster to be able
to select a master okay yes so the
answer is yes oh yes okay so you take
snapshots only on the master node all
the time right which is elected to be
master for at that point in time
actually currently we just select we
just run on one of the notes snapshot we
don't we don't bother right you don't
get into the situation of having this
snapshot not similar to the exact
version of the data no but what we are
doing what we are like would this
parameters allows you to take care of if
you for example you have seven nodes in
the cluster and your cluster got split
so like three notes talking to each
other in this photo stalking treat to
each other if your parameter is set to
four only this cluster will be able to
elect master and discuss the ribbon
master list and then you will not be
able to communicate with it it will just
not go dark so you will not be in a
situation if my backups around on this
part my backups will fail and it will
have to log in and see why they failed
their well no there will never be a
situation when we have two masters or
this parameter okay
you